if I became your full-time manager and
we started business together this was my
life literally the first thing I can say
to you as 42 year old white girls you
got your prospective good hey big boy
I like mazi a lot and grind grind I'll
be functioning with my blade garyvee all
know if y'all familiar woody
motivational speaker and they can said
man put your hand down work for seven
years straight just put your hand down
work for seven years straight [ __ ] what
everybody goes door seven years straight
and that's how you that's how you
accomplish [ __ ] in a year yeah I like
the way you think and respond to most
people in this industry phone the
independent standpoint Olivos of our
choir as artists
it's really interesting I I met with
mozzie then I met with the CMO and it
was just an interesting night
this was last night in LA and I was
laying there was like man it's so crazy
to me how I grew up how much more I
associate with mozzie than I do with
like a fortune 500 CMO it's even the
comers it's why I'm excited bout
tonight's conversation my ability like
to plug the two environments and I
didn't when I first started my company I
was more from startup world Silicon
Valley you know Facebook Twitter Tumblr
and I got into like the big brands and
now they know because it's ten years
later but then they didn't and to me
like the reason Snoop Dogg is a is like
the face of a king show like Joker's
wild like if you would have told me the
19 year old version of me that [ __ ]
the guy that I just listened to on the
chronic is gonna be is gonna be like
[ __ ] like Anderson Cooper like I
would have laughed you out of the room
but that's what happened and I don't
think people actually understand how
this [ __ ] actually plays out which is we
this is the middle the middle is when
Wiz Khalifa can walk into a boardroom
with no t-shirt on and not a boardroom
like I'm trying to get an album deal
from death row no no like actually
coca-cola that's the middle the
beginning was when this all came up in
the 80s and 90s when it was like what it
was this is the middle the next part is
that you have the leverage
the Internet is a much bigger thing than
people realize
it will only reward what the people [ __ ]
with what happens next is you have the
leverage and that's where a lot of your
decisions need to come from over the
next 20 years because even though we're
a little older we're still young as [ __ ]
Warren Buffett didn't start making real
money until he was like 63
I guess what how old are you what the 26
year old version of us doesn't realize
is we're an exact same [ __ ] dude in
our heads right now than we were 16
years ago I'll be talking to like a 20
year old be like we should like as if
like we're the same right you feel it
right well here's where I'm going with
that
I already know that's what's gonna
happen to me at 62 too so I might as
well be strategic now anyway nonetheless
tonight's theme I want to answer a
question I want to talk I want to listen
but the biggest thing that I would tell
you is if you're smart and if you listen
to me I think you can build more
leverage and I want you to run a
marathon when it doesn't seem like you
should be married running a marathon
because you're 42 does that make sense
good that to me is the [ __ ]
juxtaposition where it's like we're
[ __ ] with 25 weird a 25 and I could
do a 42 like if I was a bull tryout for
the New York Giants I'm going to make
the New York Giants
well good if you're willing to be that
ridiculous then my [ __ ] should be easy
listen I mean it if you're in that vine
place Mazel Tov then we're set because
the way I'm gonna ask you to go is way
easier to make in the Giants just be
impatient as an entrepreneur so if you
ask me what what like the thing I'm most
scared of I'm gonna go very deep right
now I'm very scared that in five years
I'm gonna get an email from a mother who
blames me for her son's suicide
let me explain how I think right now
everybody thinks they're an entrepreneur
and we know that they're not but it's
super easy to say that on your Instagram
I'm starting a Brit how many times you
guys hear somebody say I'm starting to
brand because they printed five t-shirts
with a saying the feminine boys got a
slang term and they're like yo that's my
brand right back in the day especially
the way we grew up a lot of people had a
son hustle and then when it failed and
they got a job or they got married it
just went away like nobody even knew
like feeling oh you remember you used to
[ __ ] try to sell ice cream on the
corner now everybody's putting their
[ __ ] on blast saying they're gonna be
the next this the next that so when they
lose which when the economy Falls
everyone's gonna lose they won't be able
to hide got it so what I think is gonna
happen is I think a lot of people gonna
commit suicide I really do I'm watching
it's already happening I failed
everything in school but there was one
book I didn't read it but for some
reason I got a good grade so it was a
rare moment 3 it was around a book
called The Scarlet Letter and I think
about that because I know by the way I
still don't know what the books really
about but I know enough to know the
following when you have a Scarlet Letter
and everybody can see it that [ __ ] is
hard everybody's putting themselves in a
vulnerable position right now
everybody's a model everybody's an
entrepreneur everybody and they're all
being subsidized by a fake economy
we're old we know when the economy fails
[ __ ] gets hard these kids who live in a
fake world and when you live in a fake
world it's why rich kids get into drug
problems they live in a fake world
sometimes you're six eight and that's
the trick other times you you're super
rich and you think you had something to
do with it and then you get into the
real world and here's the problem
this is so fun for me to talk about cuz
nobody talks about the rich kid who's
gonna die rich kid used to go to Harvard
coz grandpa built the [ __ ] library
right then he or she went to Goldman
Sachs or a law firm because grandpa did
that too and they hid in the machine
making a million a year that kid now is
starting a company but they're soft cuz
they're a zoo animal because they were
protected and the market doesn't give a
[ __ ] who their grandpa was and they're
gonna get exposed and they're gonna fall
hard I meet these kids every day if you
ask me who I'm more scared for the hood
kids I hang out with every day for the
[ __ ] trust them enemies not even
close
trust fund babies cuz they're gonna kill
themselves
the hood kids are just gonna blame the
president and grind I'm telling you it's
gonna be bad you know why I'm so happy
because I think everything is my fault
I'm being serious it's weird as [ __ ] it
took me a long time I'm like oh [ __ ]
because the second you think it's your
fault and you don't think anybody else
controls your [ __ ] you get happier it's
real crazy [ __ ] I think about it all
times
that'd be awesome result because they
I think it's you asked a really really
smart question I'll tell you why the
fine line between confidence and
security is super-fit thin super thin I
know and all that comes down to who are
you God if I could [ __ ] it outside of
like letting you be healthy like outside
of me giving you a pill that would make
you healthy
the next pill I would give you is to get
quiet if I tell you I don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody says about me including my
wife and mother it's true and that is
game changer and that's basically all my
content all I'm trying to do is get
people one way or the other
to that place because what happens then
is [ __ ] amazing if my mom called me
right now and said I'm disappointed in
you I don't know what the [ __ ] I did I
bring you know I talked a big game right
but still what but I'm fair now
associate respect respect to me whoever
it is right and by the way in the
culture it's grandma for some people
with dad not mom it might be your aunt
it might be your sister the few times
it's come to a head though there's just
something the way I'm wired and raised
them how I grew up
I care but I know they don't know
everything got it
like my mom just doesn't know everything
she knows real well like I was in her
she knows me she really knows men that
she doesn't know everything and that's
what happens the reason you know why I
don't judge because I don't know it's
unbelievable I can't judge I talk a bit
a lot but it's me making observations
it's not judgment it's a very difference
big difference I don't know your luck
I'll give you a good example I know in
my heart that if I was homeless I would
steal every day I think if you're
homeless you should steal I actually
believe that it's very simple why people
do what they do its context
you know and that's why this thing
matters to me so much what it comes down
to every single time is the truth the
biggest respect I put on a pedestal is
hip-hop culture it's very untrackable
it's really good at sniffing out
[ __ ] there's the reason there's
something called culture vote rose it
means they got away with it for a few
minutes
deviled ornaments out at all so much
money is why we built doors that's
people value money over their name I
lose so much money to make sure people
say nice things behind my back I don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says
yet I spend my whole life making sure
the people that actually know me say
good things behind my back it's the same
reason Motown made a huge mistake
in a lot of ways when I look at it as a
marketing business man watching current
hip-hop establishment [ __ ] on mumble rap
is maybe the most interesting thing that
I've watched in a long time I spend
ungodly amounts of time on this because
it's the same old [ __ ] it's like it's
unbelievable but mainly cuz we're older
now like the [ __ ] you know we're at the
age where the so wu-tang asked me to be
in their documentary it's been 25 years
since 36 chambers came in and I was like
oh my god when I was in college and one
of my friends wanted me to go see the
Rolling Stones and I was like groaning
so that's some old people [ __ ] that's
what whoo tang is now if a kids 18 in
college
I think when you're asking at least what
I would be thinking is how the [ __ ] do
you get everybody to give a [ __ ] without
selling out two things that undermine
the position is the most interesting
game right how do you get the youth to
give a [ __ ] how do you get everybody to
have the feelings like when you just
said that I had feelings from a from a
gent like a generation ago Mike this is
so crazy you know I agree the problem is
oh geez and legends don't do a terrible
job with respecting the youth I get it I
get it I get it that's all good girl I
believe you I just want to talk I just
want to talk love us yeah I believe it
embrace them I believe you want here's
the good news
truth is a I don't know so we're going
to talk B where I would go first back to
the truth and I saw you react to it I'd
love to know and you listen you're busy
doing your own [ __ ] but the first place
that would start with what you're asking
and that's what we're here to do tonight
is who if anybody do you authentically
[ __ ] with that is young in the game
right now and then I would start
strategizing backwards for the things
that go completely crazy you need it
everybody to get behind because there's
too much noise it's why if you look
carefully jay-z's last couple of effort
like jay-z's in a funny spot like
nobody's saying it but here's the
punchline he's a lot less relevant than
people realized right now now he's one
and he's a mold kid but but yeah but if
you watch carefully when you narrow
things you become vulnerable title was
narrow
cashed out gave up attention it's fine
everybody's entitled to it but that was
at the pinnacle we all died of this rap
game you do aho it's the [ __ ] cash
show a hundred percent way wouldn't even
matter who the [ __ ] said it a hundred
percent it depends on what you're
playing for right like like like Wayne's
last album that wasn't playing about
money that was playing just to be
creative freedom again
everybody's playing for something
different always right everybody's
fighting for something that's super fine
but I'm using it as a comp because no
matter how big you are
eventually Madonna puts out an album
that starts the process of the downside
on the flip side it's why anything can
happen on the upside like people always
spend all their time worried about the
fall-off I'm always talking about the
opportunity it's mapping it's bringing
value to certain people
it's cashing in favors from others it's
just when [ __ ] drops like I get crap all
I do I think you guys even know this
like I give love love love love but when
I have a book or a sneaker or something
I give a [ __ ] about your reconciling and
you're counting your head you're like
you know who could and my big thing is I
ask and don't expect that's why I'm also
happy right like I'll hit somebody up
that I knew I did a bunch for I'm like
yo this means a lot to me and if they're
if they don't do anything I'm not like
[ __ ] people my dad's the other
way like he's real tic for tack so I'm
very opposite like I see that version
like he's like yo I [ __ ] back in
Russia
I once like picked up his cow and like
this [ __ ] I'm like dad that's 39
years ago like you can't worry about
that [ __ ] you know he's like that I'm
the other way
I'll give giving if the person that look
I take note I'm not a [ __ ] idiot I'm
like okay
a lot of people Slough with a lot and I
always give and don't expect I like
helping people
yeah it's fine I genuinely people your
Karma's real spot like listen negativity
the wrong thing it wins the halftime
game its leading at halftime but good
always wins take what I've done for a
lot of negativity but like you said
people don't know people don't know
today so they don't know if something
happened right now all they gonna need
to tell you Jim Jones in that restaurant
with some people they not gonna say
nothing else but whoever Matt is they
don't know and they don't know they just
say you all the [ __ ] but they don't
know what they don't know I don't know
that's an honest man I'm telling you
it's so liberating when you stop judging
I looked up in like you don't know hey I
don't know anyway so a couple things let
me give you something else I think about
listen there's gonna be very basic but I
think music lives in its own cocoon I
think about distribution right makes
sense but I don't think about it the way
the music industry does for example what
song are we gonna give some YouTube
person to put in their vlog what song
are we gonna ask some eSports kid while
they're paying for tonight to play on
repeat in the background I'll tell you
that's where Drake is very smart like
Drake is a marketer as much as he is an
artist cuz Drake thinks about
distribution Drake doesn't show up on
ninja's for night Channel for fun
that's what I want you to do I want you
to pick a song and be like okay this is
good for you know teenyboppers this is
good for eSports people this is good for
we want this playing during the garden
like warmups got it
distribution like if you want some of
the pop you need distribution that
doesn't make sense I always had knows
this I always talk about good Charlotte
because I think that was the last time I
played Madden in like 96 97 in that when
you were making your dynasty team good
Charlotte was playing on repeat you had
all these kids in the hood me like oh
good Charlie's [ __ ] rap fresh I'm
like Madden
well when they put one of my records on
one of them I love those Matador MBA
them what am i reck'n you don't want
existence crazy like that just as soon
as one hole the end then that's crazy
give me an example of something that's
like a given let's play here we're
having fun what would be a dream
scenario men's health if it Men's Health
magazine
let's [ __ ] maggot both I'm so happy
right now let me help you
the reason I am Who I am is cuz the
level that I [ __ ] on both hunt both of
us let me explain
men's help GQ there's 53 Instagram
accounts that if we get you on you'll
get 50 times more than those two things
if you're on the cover of men's health
if you get 53 of the right influencers
and meme accounts and fitness you'll get
way more attention next there's 35
podcasts and [ __ ] that will make it
way bigger than that like if you ask me
why companies or big artists are losing
as they're playing the guys when gold
link went on Fallon nobody [ __ ]
watched it's just I don't think people
get it
I still pray that the Wall Street
Journal Fast Company or Inc or the New
York Times reach out to me now I make
them need me it's cat and mouse it's
boys and girls you know guys get good
girls let the girl come to you that like
that's what you want to do with this
like so spending any energy trying to
get them versus diversifying the
distribution within a digital phone
environment I think will give you a lot
more leverage I think about everything
as how many bullets in the chamber
that's all
I would triple down on your audience are
you doing Instagram lives at all good
how often it's hard it's hard I don't
you know dad you know the thing listen
I'll be very honest the thing that you
know as we've been getting to know each
other you know it's the same old [ __ ]
you get to do with somebody you give a
[ __ ] you start paying attention a little
more I'll be honest with you what's most
interesting for me with you if I became
your full-time manager and we started a
business together this is my life
literally the first thing I would say to
you as 42 year old white girls that
would be my macro business strategy for
jindo meaning I think I think you who
win that game
I think you'd win that game and let me
tell you what about that game you want
to talk about real bags some bags
oops not hanging out with Martha Stewart
for fun
and she's not hanging out with him for
fun either you have street cred it's so
valuable when the streets [ __ ] with you
and your mature Oh
the biggest advantage I think of people
that are in a mature state of legend
status within hip-hop is the streets are
always gonna [ __ ] with you regardless
it's kind of what that mozzie talk where
it really he really caught it where I
was like you can't have an album where
everything is Street Street Street and
then that's the album that means you
didn't do anything to expand it's real
great that Yo Gotti wife Emily cheering
your album but like where's Jessica
Simpson where is Dolly Parton's where's
Kate Hudson you sure I'm going thing
that should be in the hold
yeah do you know much more money Nelly
made when Kelly Rowland sang the hook do
you know what happened at Kendrick
Lamar's career when Taylor Swift had a
song with him it's not 1993 anymore
where everyone has to act thug every
minute yeah it's about paper now I think
you should lean in heavy into Fitness
one of them and what I would do is I
would have him DM like a hundred fifty
Fitness brands jump ropes bars protein
shot you know I don't know what you [ __ ]
with just DM be like yo literally as
simple as this keep doing your thing
like what you're doing keep going that's
it see who responds to that Fitness is
your is your calling card it's not even
close
it's not even close by the way it's your
truth and that's where all the money is
no yes in your treat that's what the
money
do music and fitness tune out everything
get focused get smart have the right
meetings figure out where you want to
take the fitness energy how do you want
to monetize is it getting a million a
year to be the face of a protein bar is
it selling $100 course is it getting you
know retro to pay you a hundred thousand
as an influencer there's a lot of ways
to do it but first the crews got inside
to now all the noise all we give a [ __ ]
about is number one giving a [ __ ] about
our audience once in a while replying
going live the ship watch what I do not
what I say
[Music]